rise and shine rise and shine how many
I've been singing this non-stop what do
you guys think of this didn't we have
Kylie what anything she touches now I
know we were laughing so hard even the
other night with her being like how did
this become a thing
like this is so funny to us like all the
memes that they were making so stupid
funny and the one of like where it's
your mom's face but it's and that the
computer closing I would like to treat
it like this
did you see it as well a fast one to me
is when stormy says oh what she's like I
don't want it I don't want to know when
stormy you think she says like [ __ ] oh
did you see that no oh my gosh that's
the best one rise and shine
the one was like The Voice competition
and they were all oh yeah yeah rise and
shine do you get on the phone with each
other and you're like rise and shine
today you were like everyone rise and
shut no I'm not to wake up rain that way
in the morning you do and he loves it
where did this come from dude dude mom
wake you up with rise and shine is this
a family tradition did she no no I have
my good morning song which I won't sing
to you right now why are you shining so
I sing that in the morning okay I got
all of them when I wake them up maybe
they could do a rain like make a rise
and shine
I like morning song remix and then like
is there a possibility that we could
throw in like just one beat of jam
[Music]
[Laughter]
right Irina no she's like no thank you
hey thank you you mentioned that you
might be ready to say goodbye to Keeping
Up with the Kardashians where are you at
on that um I'm just decided to spend
more time as a mom and you know put more
of my energy there but I'm not saying
goodbye I think you'll have to see more
of it on the new season season 18 just
crazy isn't airing yet but it's being
filmed okay and currently do you want in
this room do you think the show can
continue going if you lose a sister yeah
I mean we definitely love Courtney and
we will miss Courtney and whatever she
decides to do but people come people go
all the time
this family we are feel like at the
revolving door so Courtney might leave
this week she'll be back they all come
back we can do another spin-off like
just just Kim and Khloe take take
Calabasas amazing in the condo with all
of our kids and see how that goes
this sounds like a show to me for me how
did this all come together I love doing
collabs with my sisters it makes me feel
kind of nostalgic yeah we haven't really
done anything together the three of us
and so long and it really has at least
for a decade really been the three of us
until we kind of branched out and
started doing our own projects so to me
this is was like a no-brainer to do a
collab with Kourtney and khloé what was
the first fragrance that you realized
like I want this I like this smell this
is me because when you smell these they
are so different I think I might be a
Kourtney fool really
yeah describe like the different smells
for each one and why do you think that
kind of goes with your personalities or
your knives well mine is actually very
sweet mine's Jasmine lilac and Subarus
are like their main sense but mine is
just my signature scent it's something
that I've always been drawn to they're
my favorites notes and I'm to combine
them all and have they work really well
on your natural body oils so I love
they'll give you know us you smell
Courtney's and it's like oh my god this
is Courtney if you smell mine you're
like oh my god this is mine it's not
mine just the diamond idea behind this
where did that come from I just always
felt like I wanted to do a diamond
fragrance I used to collect these
Tiffany paperweights back in the day and
they've always think is worth three
fabulous big old diamonds right it was
definitely Kim's idea the diamonds and
then we kind of picked our colors you
did do you have a lot of say and what is
it like working together do you you know
are you like yes everything came
whatever you want are you like no I have
to have this and she's like but but well
can't this is Kim's expertise she's been
with the fragrance world for so long and
she's so successful at it so I think
Kourtney and I both definitely take her
lead and she knows what she's doing but
when it came to our sense that was very
personal we all would say if we liked a
scent or not but it was really up to us
as the scent part of it all yeah Kim is
so good at this that we definitely
respect her opinion but I was very happy
to get the pink diamond yeah I thought
that was like the most you and I thought
you were very yellow diamond makes me
want a yellow diamond when looking for a
gift so this is coming to us we're in
the Bahamas you were there for the you
had the family vacation and you went so
well what was that like and did you swim
with the pigs and like we're gonna get
to see that on the show right well we
actually just went on a private vacation
when we were we had a six-week break
like real life real life yeah and we I
was my mama's case you were wondering
Chloe had never been before it was
really exciting to see and just to have
this like private vacation just us
sisters with our kids they all had so
much fun together it was so just the
experience was awesome and we did go
some with the pigs ah you know they do
like Instagram versus real life it was
definitely one of those but it was
awesome we had great Instagram shots but
I just envisioned this island of pigs
that probably don't they are aggressive
cuz they want your food I just thought
they were like sweet little piglet no
there yeah there Biggles
yeah hogs and it was it was an
experience she thought there was gonna
be like 200 pigs just swimming and like
Peppa Pig and there was like maybe five
and they were just like rummaging just
to our big bag of Cheetos I loved it but
you know it's like check okay did that I
don't need to go every time I go through
well I thought well we're gonna sing
Kevin Frazier to some of the pigs and he
can like you know they'll probably just
trick grab onto those dry elbows of his
you know man throwing you under the bus
cuz you didn't bring me Kevin um did you
renewed your vows yes I love this I'm
about to renew my vows in December I
think it's the most beautiful thing to
do so what brought five years I thought
it was just the five year mark after
being done having all of our kids and
wanting to have that memory with our
children there because I know North was
at our wedding but all of our other kids
obviously weren't even born yet so it
was really special to have all of our
kids there and have that moment do the
vows change I think before and after
kids are before and after life when you
first say them you're like one thing and
now after five years there's got to be
something different there yeah well we
had really traditional vows our first
time around and so we wrote something
that was just more intimate and special
to us and where we're at now five years
later so it definitely is different I
love that how's the relationship change
five year it seems like the food's just
yesterday we're all like
I mean just I think after having kids
yeah it's just such a life changer our
life is so different I feel like this is
when life really begins and it's been so
much fun to be on this journey with
someone that just brings you on this
like whirlwind of a life that I never
dreamed that I would have so it's been a
lot of fun I love that and the fact that
you guys all have your kids and they're
around ish the same it this is amazing
this is like such a cool little tribe
ladies we're single at the same time
right now are you double is there like a
double Kardashian date ever
no no oh you really don't like I would
think I'd be like a double set up well
I'm not really dating right okay really
I should double set them up like on a
blind date right I don't think we do
dates or blind dates I don't mind dating
but and I got to present on a blind date
so I do both you are not a good date er
no IDs get on come front like friendly
group settings you want to do a group
date just got to find the guys you could
do a group and you can sprinkle that you
could like match make and you could
sprinkle in like 15 and you can just
weed them out like The Hunger Games yeah
like as you go yeah I feel like Kim cut
him he's out you know you guys have been
through so much in your life but what do
you look what are you looking for now
you're not looking I'm not but I'm not
like in ten I'm just super happy and
content and I'm focused on work and life
taking care of me my body and soul and
true and I just I'm having so much fun
with her and when I want to I will it's
not some deliberate thing yeah she ain't
that hard about do you think about it
Courtney I am also in a space where I
just don't care to distract with you
know I'm not like I don't know I'm just
like living life and whatever happens
happens but I'm not like thinking about
I'm not putting my energy there well
you're gonna have to put it when you
walk through the grocery store with your
scent on because then everyone's gonna
fall in love with instantly I think all
right I've prepared a mom speed round
for you who is most likely to skip page
during the bedtime story to get to the
end you get out of there yeah well not
to get out of there cuz I'm falling
asleep every time I read a book with one
of my kids I fall asleep before them at
the same time we're both like snoring
there's like so many nights that Connie
has to come in and be like hello who is
the most likely to sneak some artwork in
the garbage can I do overtime but she
doesn't do I like she doesn't know yet
right like make me all these things
Thanks I have a kids art archive no way
yes I think is our one day I will
present to them their art if they want
to put it up in their apartments when
they're all doing whatever they want I
have a an archive for them that's
awesome who's most likely to shorten
into the momager next not me
you think me yeah I think I could get
with Jojo see well if that's what I mean
if that's what they wanted to do yeah
yes but sometimes I think as a mom I can
say yes to things that they really want
to do in the moment and I think they're
ready because they asked me so many
times but I think I got a like chill I
think that's like my new thing is like
not doing it yeah even when they want to
do it because ultimately right now it's
just a phase when I saw North with Jojo
see wha it must have been hard on you
because that's a lot of color it's a lot
of sparkles it's a lot of like textures
like I know that doesn't go with your
aesthetic oh you know so like she came
out what was it her house it was great
fine
yes you just leave that there yeah and
you know I want my kids to have fun and
do whatever they want so I'm not going
to like you know pressure her to want to
be as neutral as meaning yeah at the
time when she wants to Jojo si will bow
though are you like I'm dying a little
yes yes but but I think she's like moved
on to like different hairstyles now good
so it's a thing so you let him go
through the phase so you get all the
bows you do it until you're over it and
then now it's like different hairstyle
you're done okay who suppose their kids
the most I actually probably Chloe I
soyal my kids I try to not give them
lots of gifts for their birthday I'm
like the anti I mean she's 18 months old
and yeah first baby so I think you do
more with the first two in the year I
know cuz you're like waiting for any
opportunity to get them something like
the things you've jumped your whole life
to get yeah men know we're just on Elmo
right now like I'm buying our car Elmo
yeah not yet
who do you think will have another baby
next well not me definitely not maybe
Chloe how would you say yesterday you
wanted another zero maybe I said if the
situation is right zero and I don't like
right now I'm super content with just
true yeah and I get I guess just I have
to say in this situation I don't feel
like it's not kind of one and done -
yeah and I I never thought I would have
only one child but I am so obsessed with
her and I love it so much I definitely
don't think I would feel incomplete if I
didn't have more but another one would
just add more love to the house so I
don't know yet it's gonna be it's hard
this is like a family making kind of
family yeah I could just have one that
goes against everything that is it it
really is and that's the only thing was
I just like born to believe I need to
have so many kids I don't know but I'm
so happy with just her so only time will
tell
last thing what is possibly next oh it's
like everyone always asked like what
more do you want to do like no no I
are you tired I don't want to do
anything else like I had a good showing
I'm really good focused on like beauty
fragrance skims law school mom she's not
necessarily in that order but that is
more than enough for me
is there something that's too much that
you think you could drop
no I love every last thing that I do
anything that I would want to drop I
will I would have done it already
[Music]